oh I'm not lurking uh Lester wanted to
inspect the peep holes because evidently
some of them had been installed
backwards so I said well I'll do it and
he said you know the good time is 2:
a.m. so I'm I'm lying I just wanted to
say I'm sorry oh apology accepted
friendship mended you're hired no no I
don't want to do this show I just want
to hang out of course we'll do that all
the time eight shows a week and bradi
you're fired wait a minute wait this guy
I've seen him get out acted by a horse
maybe he was but but I'm guessing that
horse enjoyed himself on set that day
because he got to spend it with Charles
Hayden Savage who was probably kind to
him and fed him a fist full of Oats out
of his
palm and I bet that horse didn't realize
how good he had it until he had another
scene partner on another set who just
wrote him and wrote him and wrote him
and wrote him and rote him and rote him
and rote him until he couldn't take it
anymore
and I bet that horse wishes he could say
sorry but he can't not because he's a
horse because he's a little messed up
emotionally so all he can do is hate
himself uh and and and wish he were dead
for hurting his best friend and that
someone would turn him into glue apology
accepted okay okay I'll do the play by
the way that horse want a Psy for that
scene what's a Psy it's an Emmy for
horses you're still here it's over
go
[Music]
home go you know if you have any
adjustments I'm very flexible and I've
always found it's best to be
honest I bet you would have made a much
better Ferris do you mean that oh I want
to but he's
[Music]
perfect